hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 4 of
Plato's Republic he is going to near the
end discuss the nature of injustice
within the human soul or personality
within the human person what's going on
when we not only do the wrong things but
we we choose to do the wrong things it
becomes part of who we are we become
licentiousness of actions like arguing
with our neighbors more often than we
should over stupid things what's
actually going on there and Plato is not
going to provide us with the complete
discussion of this that's deferred until
later on in the Republic in book 8
within which there's specific
discussions of this type and this type
and this type but in general what he's
going to say is that injustice is not
just the result of but is actually
constituted by a disharmony within the
soul and this is analogous to a kind of
disharmony within a political community
in which different occupational classes
don't work well with each other and get
into conflict and some
even faction and civil war with each
other now in this this section he brings
up a number of different examples of
injustice prior to to going into what
the shape of injustice is he talks about
a good person and the things that they
won't do they're not going to withhold
and embezzle a deposit of gold or silver
right so they're not engaging in a kind
of theft or betrayal of their agreements
there they're not going to be faithless
in keeping of oaths or other agreements
they're not going to engage in adultery
neglect of parents neglect of the due
service of the gods and you know we can
think of all sorts of other things as
well the point is every bit of injustice
every kind of doing wrong for Plato can
be traced back to this and it connects
with his notion of the tripartite soul
so let's remind ourselves what that
means Plato thinks that just like within
the ideal city there is the function of
the guardians there is analogous to that
the highest part of the soul which is
the intellectual or rational part though
you know the the logic a part right the
one that has logos the one that can
think things out and make good decisions
and that part is the the part that
should be ruling then there's the
spirited part of the soul spirited there
of course translating Lumos which is a
difficult Greek term to adequately
render into English it's sometimes
translated as the passionate part of the
soul but you don't want to strictly
identify it with what we call passion
today and that's a middle part of the
soul the part that gets angry or riled
up the part that helps to defend us
against outside threats and in Justices
and the part that can also work within
us either for or against the other parts
of the soul it's the part that gives us
the energy to get things done you might
say then we have and here in this
discussion Plato is going to talk about
in the singular but it's really in the
plural the
appetites the epitome me I in Greek
these are desires for things like eating
and drinking and having sex and laying
around and looking at Netflix all day
plain of course doesn't talk about
Netflix but that would fit in there as
well I think because it would be an
appetite and the appetites cannot
control themselves they need the
rational and the spirited part to
provide them with some sort of guidance
some sort of limits and to enforce those
limits upon them so what Plato sets out
for us is the ideal of a well a well
oriented a well ordered a well
structured soul which is really that of
a harmony and he actually does use a
musical metaphor here he talks about
having first attained a self mastery and
beautiful order within himself and
having harmonized these three parts or
principles the notes or intervals of
three terms quite literally the lowest
the highest and the mean and all others
there may be between them and having
linked and bound all three together and
made of himself a unity one person
instead of many self-controlled and in
unison this is the way that that Plato
depicts justice within the soul so how
should we then understand acting
unjustly or engaging in injustice
producing injustice and even worse being
unjust so here there's a lot of
interesting metaphors and again these
these can be analogized to the big city
and then brought back to the individual
soul Plato talks about there being a
civil war
of the three parts against each other
and in in terms of the city this is
fairly easy to understand again you
might want to look at book 8 where
there's more specific discussion about
how this takes place how the different
groups within the society find
themselves at odds with each other and
conflict with each other in terms of the
individual soul what happens is
the rationale the spirited and the
appetite of parts of the soul do not get
on the same page and are not able to
harm mo harmoniously work together each
of them doing their their proper
function and so we have this break down
into a civil war or a faction you might
say that that it ties in with each of
them attempting to do what is not its
function or to make the other parts
serve them in ways that they they
shouldn't now notice that Plato is not
saying well each part is like its own
little thing by itself compartmentalized
off and none of them should actually
tell the other what to do as a matter of
fact when the souls working rightly as
we said the rational part tells
everybody what to do the spirited part
enforces it and the appetites do what
they do within the limits set out by
that so it's not as if it's anarchy
right or compartmentalization instead
it's supposed to be this this this way
of ruling but there's all sorts of ways
in which this can go wrong so the
spirited part of the soul could be
driving the person and subordinating the
rational part to its desires for honor
social status the appetites could make
it the the soul a sort of you know
conform to the human notion that reason
is and can only ever be the slave of the
passions as a matter of fact there's
room for the human viewpoint it's just
that the human viewpoint from a platonic
standpoint is going to be engaged in
injustice within the the soul right and
even the rational part could could go
wrong in certain ways although Plato
doesn't talk that much about that he
uses other language that I think is
worth dwelling on and considering
because it helps us figure out what's
going on here
they meddle with each other they look
over each other's work and say you
should be doing things this way right
and they're not supposed to be doing
that other than the rational part
looking looking over them
they interfere with each other they get
in the way of each other they hinder
each other so that they don't do their
proper function here's where we could
think of an example what if the rational
part actually had wrongheaded ideas very
aesthetic ideas and said appetites you
shouldn't indulge yourself at all not
only is sex off the table and toxicants
are off the table and the food that you
eat is going to be the bare minimum to
survive when there's actually no need to
do that well that would be interference
wouldn't it revolt they revolt and they
attempt to you know place themselves
over the others reason you know could be
imperious in some respect the spirited
part could try to take control the
appetites can try to take control
confusion confusing one for the other
mixing themselves up this is what
happens within a human being and this
produces vices the vices of
foolishness or ignorance you know which
is opposed to that of wisdom the vice of
cowardice which is opposed to the vice
of courage the vice of intemperance or
self-indulgence which is opposed to the
vice of temperance or moderation and
then finally the vice itself of
injustice which leads us to doing all
these bad behaviors like committing
adultery or breaking our our agreements
with people or robbing temples as
another famous thing it's sort of like
robbing banks in ancient times because
temples are often a place where deposits
were made so the vices the vices then
can be understood using this model as a
sort of disease a disease you know by
analogy to virtue being health health
being a proper ordering of the body
disease of the soul ugliness
shamefulness is another way of
translating it a lack of nobility a lack
of what it makes things attractive
that's what what vices are
weaknesses this is another great way to
think about vices a vice is a bad habit
but it's also a susceptibility to make
the wrong decisions based on the
attractiveness or the repugnance of
things that are largely outside of
ourselves the person whose appetites are
in charge and too strong well they can
be led around by sex or by food or buy
you know intoxication or whatever else
it is
they can also be led around by a desire
for security or a desire to not have to
do work the person who is being led
around by their spirited parts it could
be cowardice right but it could also be
a tendency to be too aggressive with
people you know to compete with in the
social arena and bring to a more honor
to oneself than is actually deserved
insisting on reinforcing one's own
social status at the expense of others
that's a weakness so we can go on with
this what what do these do what is the
problem with us well they make a person
sole dis harmonious our souls are
already dis harmonious and the goal of
you might say platonic virtue ethics is
to make us move more and more towards
being an actual unity but we can also go
in the other direction where we feel as
if we're at war with with ourselves we
we can't be the same person from moment
to moment and the result of this is that
the life that one's living even if you
picture it to yourself as one that
encompasses many things that are
understood as goods some of which may be
genuine good some of which may be
apparent Goods one's life is not good as
Plato says through Socrates one's life
is not worth living the life of the
person who is addicted to fame is not
really worth living even if they do
manage to become famous for a while the
life of the greedy person the life of
the person who is always you know giving
in to fear is
not really a fully human life and
therefore is not a good life so what
we've got here is a depiction of how
injustice works within the soul and how
it's connected to these different parts
of the soul and Plato's tripartite
psychology engaging in overreaching and
engaging in faction or civil war
you